à guyancourt la ville vient de lancer
les festivités pour les dix ans de la
batterie la salle prévoit jusqu'à la fin
de mai une série de concerts avec une
programmation éclectique jazz classique
reggae ou encore pop au tarif spécial de
10 euros la place écoutez elle est
unique parce que justement elle est
transversal les transversales avec
l'éducation donc l'école de musique elle
est transversal avec les studios avec
des professionnels avec des
professionnels en devenir
voilà cette dimension est quand même dès
le départ
importante pour pour nous a dit en cour
d'avoir vraiment un public varié après
un public aussi en direction de
l'éducation mais aussi en direction
du territoire